[Musique]
nous sommes le 20 avril 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 elle les a invités aujourd'hui je
reçois sophistique alain schmitt
responsable des relations entreprises
pour les cf fille de montigny le
bretonneux et d'orly elle évoquera les
portes ouvertes de l'établissement il
sera donc question d'éducation plus
particulièrement d'apprentissage
actuellement seuls 5,2 pour cent des
jeunes de 15 à 24 ans sont en
apprentissage en france contre 16% en
allemagne et puis avec damart ses mails
gérontologue et nous parlerons aussi de
la conférence annoncée à promo paul à
saint quentin en yvelines autour de la
notion de bientraitance des personnes
âgées
l'établissement a changé de nom a
récemment le cfaa de l'eau rozoy
montigny le bretonneux et nous allons en
parler avec sophie cicala
schmidt comme on soir vous êtes
responsable des relations entreprises et
je le disais il ya un changement non par
le plus d'établissements de l'eau rozoy
dorénavant c'est le cfi ça change quoi
ce nom alors dans la réalité ça change
pas grand chose pour pour les jeunes et
les parents qui sont sur le territoire
simplement c'est le rapprochement de
deux écoles une qui se trouve donc que
vous l'avez dit à montigny-le-bretonneux
une autre dans le 94 à orly parce
qu'elles sont sur la même filière à
savoir l'industrie donc une alliance est
créé pour devenir l'école connecté au
futur de l'industrie et il y aura des
portes ouvertes sur les deux campus
samedi 22 avril de 9h à 13h présente à
nous un petit peu justement
l'établissement et les formations que
vous allez proposer que vous proposez
ouais bah ouais donc durant cette
matinée
nous allons représenter notre cursus qui
va du bac pro jusqu'au bac + 5 sur trois
pôles d expertise à savoir les réseaux
et le génie informatique
nous avons aussi
l'électronique et la robotique et enfin
l'énergie et la domotique donc basset
formation se déroule sur deux ans ou
trois ans à c'est le cas de nos bacs
pros on a des formations qui existent
depuis de nombreuses années et puis
chaque année on a on a des ouvertures et
c'est le cas sur cette prochaine rentrée
voit peut-être évoqué plus globalement
si la question de l'alternance parce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure lors des
titres ce chiffre 5,2 pour cent des
jeunes de 15 à 24 ans qui sont en
apprentissage en france ils sont plus de
7% en allemagne il ya une vraie
différence
comment ça s'explique que
l'apprentissage l'alternance ne
séduisent pas autant en france qu'en
allemagne
alors c'est vrai que l'alternance est
souvent proposé comme une fois
finalement deux par défaut voie de
garage quelques fois quand on n'arrive
pas à savoir où il va de garage comme
vous le dites qui a aussi une image un
peu vieillissante sur des métiers
effectivement très traditionnel très
manuelle mais à tout le monde ne sait
pas encore que effectivement on peut
faire de l'alternance sur tous les
niveaux de formation puisque comme je
voulais dit on va jusqu'au bac +5 et que
de plus en plus c'est une voie de
l'excellence des jeunes qui choisissent
de venir y aura sur des métiers d'avenir
aussi vous avez certainement large et on
est sur des nouvelles technologies sur
le métier qui effectivement à ce que
vous parlez de l'imaginaire qui est très
décalé à la reine voilà puisqu'on a des
déformations cybersécurité par exemple
en robotique et on a des partenaires
très innovant puisque on travaille avec
des start up mais on travaille aussi
avec des groupes qui recrutent
énormément comme airbus et qui souhaite
travailler avec avec nous vous parlez de
ces entreprises qui recrutent justement
vous êtes en contact puisque c'est votre
mission au sein de l'établissement
ces entreprises sont demandeuses
aujourd'hui manque de main d'oeuvre dans
certains certaines branches certains
domaines on a vraiment des secteurs
d'activité où l'apprentissage est
vraiment le premier passeport vers
l'emploi puisque derrière ça va
permettre effectivement de rentrer avec
un cdi puisque l'apprentissage sera
presque considérée comme une période
d'essai pendant pendant les deux ans de
formation est on est on vous l'avait dit
sur des secteurs nouveaux porteurs
devait tourner vers l'avenir un
connectés puisqu'on à défaut des
formations très
et très pointu on va parler des portes
ouvertes justement ces portes ouvertes
qui se déroule le 22 avril je le
rappelle renseignez vous sur le site
internet ans et qui s'affiche sur les
deux campus aussi bien mon unique orly
vous allez leur dire quoi aux jeunes
pour les séduire que justement il ya des
possibilités de cdi qui est un vrai
salaire qu'on apprend un métier qu'on
est directement dans l'entreprise qu'on
va les accompagner dans leur recherche
aussi c'est souvent ce qui est vrai
surtout les parents or le lait les deux
écoles c'est affi et plus largement les
écoles de la chambre de commerce
accompagne les étudiants dans leur
recherche d'entreprise on les prépare à
l'employabilité au travers d'ateliers
avec des coachs et internes ou externes
à l'établissement pendant ces portes
ouvertes ils vont pouvoir échanger aussi
avec les jeunes qui sont déjà intégrés
qui vont leur dire quel a été leur
parcours à la fois les réussites les
échecs parce qu'il faut pas se cacher
que parfois il ya des moments difficiles
en alternance mais ils sont accompagnés
par les formateurs qui sont de vrais
spécialistes pluridisciplinaires des
experts dans leur domaine mais aussi les
conseillers relations entreprises qui
font partie de mon équipe mais je
voudrais aussi préciser que cette
alternance concerne aussi les adultes la
formation continue et les adultes
peuvent aussi venir se former dans les
établissements ils peuvent venir se
renseigner lors des portes ouvertes
il faut même rappeler quand même que
l'île de france fait partie des régions
pilotes qui a étendu l'âge de
l'apprentissage jusqu'à 30 ans donc
c'est là aussi une possibilité pour les
jeunes adultes qui cherchent de
nouvelles de nouvelles voies de se
tourner vers l'apprentissage et puis
effectivement on peut aussi faire de
l'alternance à tout âge avec les
contrats de professionnalisation voir la
formation continue qu'on peut proposer
effectivement et puis juste un clin
d'oeil un pour terminer parce que j'ai
vu que l un de vos jeunes apprentis
avait été distinguée récemment damien
rautureau deux médailles d'or
départemental régional ou au concours
des meilleurs apprentis de france
pour la catégorie maintenance des
véhicules voilà ça pour le pour le site
d'orly c'est vrai que ce soit sur
montigny ou dans le 94
nos formateurs ont la volonté de faire
participer nos jeunes dans les
différents métiers au concours
professionnel est souvent revient avec
de belles distinctions
donc ça a été le cas dans cet exemple
que vous citez merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous parler de ses portes ouvertes
qui se déroule ça
dit une fois de plus ' renseignez-vous
sur l'alternance puisque on embauche
dans ces secteurs là est difficile de
recruter dans le secteur du service à la
personne justement c'est le constat qui
a été fait par pôle emploi dans son
enquête annuelle sur les besoins en main
d'oeuvre pour l'année 2010 est
l'entreprise altruiste spécialisés dans
ce secteur organisent une conférence le
vendredi 21 avril thématique la
bientraitance dans l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées la gérontologue tomar
ses mails hadmar les échanges nicolas
d'ambri mélanie poquet sont elle est là
dans les yvelines plus de 1300 projets
de recrutements sont prévus pour l'année
2010 est dans le secteur de l'aide à
domicile
problème près de 60% de ces recrutements
sont difficiles à trouver
et pour en parler je suis avec tam art
se mêlent gérontologue clinicienne
bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors pourquoi c'est si compliqué de
trouver des personnes qui souhaitent
travailler dans ce secteur d'activité
écoutez j'ai fait dire que je suppose
mais en fait je connais un pc puisque je
suis formatrice et j'ai contact avec
cette personne qui travaille au métier à
domicile d'ailleurs toutes les chances
de la gériatrie et pas deux bref tous
ceux qui travaillent dans la gériatrie
qu est-ce que vous accepteriez de
travailler pour à peu près 9 099 euros
l'heure donc vous dites que c'est un
problème de salaires c'est entre autres
c'est un problème des salaires c'est le
travail est difficile la dépendance
devient de plus en plus ça augmente de
plus en plus les personnes que
avant c'était déjà dans des maisons de
retraite on les garde
plus longtemps à domicile ça veut dire
qu'il ya des personnes dépendantes
domicile ma spécialité c'est vraiment
les personnes âgées désorientées ce
qu'on appelle la démence de type
alzheimer et apparentés et c'est ça pose
problème de compréhension de langage il
ya des claques à dieu c'est vito
agressivité des adultes quand on n'est
pas vraiment fort mais quand on n'a pas
cet autre regard sur sur ces personnes
on prend pour soi je vais vous donner
des exemples les personnes âgées
désorientées qui accusent les médias de
masse il de tuer la volée des boys par
exemple auquel à milo dans son lit or
c'est tout à fait autre chose quand on
ne comprend pas ça blesse et ça c'est
c'est connu c'est très dire
alors hier les salaires il ya les
distances que cette personne que ces
dames là en général ce sont des dames
qui doivent encourir d'un endroit à
l'autre pour travailler trois aires où
désert j'ai une personne après dés ou
trois héroïnes hersh nôtres alors
justement les conditions de travail les
situations que vous évoquez demain
vendredi 21 avril vous allez l'évoqué à
travers la conférence qui est organisé
par la société altruiste
quel message vous allez souhaité
transmettre à travers cette conférence
alors
si on parle si on part dans la
philosophie un peu quand même
ce sont deux prises de conscience en
fait prise de conscience des sociétés un
jour ne seront vieux on espère tous
restés à la maison enfin chez soi
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mort ça veut dire que
ça nous concerne tous certains plus tôt
certains plus tard mais ça nous arrive à
tous et si vous voulez être vraiment
bien traités à notre tour il faudrait
que nous soyons bien traitant maintenant
et c'est donner vraiment des moyens pour
le faire c'est aussi en grande partie
s'informer et se former
quand on n'a pas d'informations quant on
n'a pas d'informations on se plante être
autonome ça veut dire aussi être utile
là je pars en paix de la pyramide de
maslow par hamid a besoin universel
nous avons tous besoin d'être utile de
se sentir apprécié et estimé
et cette auto mines dans cette petite
motivation
enfin nous donne quelques hectares
depuis ce livre est justement cette
autonomie s s'entretient avec des
personnes qui viennent aider à domicile
et à travers notamment la bientraitance
qu'est-ce que ça recouvre le terme
devient très la bientraitance c'est
justement ce que je viens vous
vous dire la bientraitance et écoutés
par les considérer l'autre comme un
adulte et pas comme un enfant ce qui
souvent les soignants en fait les
soignants sont en général bienveillante
si il y à des actes qui ne sont pas sauf
sauf vraiment
dès qu en plus isolé et quand il y à des
actes
par exemple on appelle le très
facilement une personne âgée mamie ben
mami à quel droit
c'est toujours une personne ça c'est pas
des mauvaises volontés c'est vraiment en
méconnaissance des connaissances la
manière de dialoguer avec ces personnes
la manière de l'écouté la manière de
steam est ce que je viens de dire
donc vous dites que c'est la
connaissance et à travers la formation
qu'on pourra choquer entre les cas de
maltraitance que c'est qu'à travers la
formation même l'information ça devient
p mais ces quais à travers de la
formation que ces choses vont passer car
c'était notre public c'est un autre vous
dire ma spécialité c'est vraiment ma
spécialité si l'on peut dire
je suis vert vraiment le personnes âgées
désorientées leur nombre ne cesse pas
d'augmenter et qui rendent la vie des
soignants
[Musique]
pas facile c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités pour ce soir replay sur notre
site internet via notre application
mobile également nouvelle édition du 7 8
les invités de ce sera mardi aux
horaires habituels puisque lundi notre
antenne sera mobilisé pour les résultats
du premier tour de la présidentielle
n'oubliez pas bien évidemment d'aller
voter dimanche
[Musique]